welcome to episode 67 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i interviewed rav aurora
rav arora is a blogger and essayist who
has written articles featured in the new
york post
city journal colette globe and mail and
more he's one of the only journalists
that i actually kind of trust
his articles use data and statistics to
disprove some of the narratives that are
popular these days
remember to hit subscribe if you enjoy
this episode every sunday and wednesday
this episode is brought to you by hover
a domain name vendor
something that makes hover special other
than the fact that they're sponsoring
this episode
is it has a ton of options for different
endings on domains
it has over 300 domain name extensions
to choose from when building your brand
online
you'll find excellent technical support
available to answer any questions you
may have
their support team doesn't upsell you
free who is privacy protection
clean user experience and monthly sales
on popular top level domains
check them out at hover.com mp and get a
10
discount with that referral link on all
new purchases hover.com
mp also linked below i hope you enjoyed
this episode
[Music]
rav aurora welcome to my podcast hey
it's good to be here
i've been excited to talk to you you're
quite the upcoming
writer uh nowadays i keep seeing your
articles pop up
yeah yeah that's awesome um i do have
one i do have one confession to make
and that is that uh when you invited me
first on your podcast which was
um last summer like july or august
you invited me to come on and at that
point i had only written like one or two
articles
and they were like blowing up and people
were reading them and i was just like oh
oh my goodness like people
you know actually care about what i was
writing and it was so overwhelming
and then i told you i'm like no i'm too
busy can we do it later but really i was
just lying to you and so
so we postponed it to like september or
november
and then i think you got busy and then
it got postponed to like february
so now here we are finally talking it's
better though you've got many more
articles out
can we can we start off just give a
brief background about
who you are and what it is that you do
to my audience
yeah um so i'm 20 now
i'm first year university student um
studying criminology
um and last summer i started writing
about race criminal justice
culture so i consistently write on these
topics for
primarily the new york post now but also
the globe and mail
in the past and colette magazine and a
few other places
um yes so that's basically what i do now
just write articles and
do school on the side on the side
yeah so how does how do your peers your
articles are quite
i wouldn't say inflammatory i love them
i think they're spot on
but they're completely going against the
mainstream
narrative so and we'll get into some of
the articles you've written a little bit
later but
how do your peers react to you like
are you doing okay in school given the
fact that you're writing these articles
yeah um well schooling is all online
right now
and and in my classes i don't really
know anybody so it's just all
online and i just do it but otherwise
it's boring
yeah it is and it's hard to maintain
self-discipline too
online schooling it's like you don't
feel like doing it sometimes and
you know you can fall behind and it's
hard to keep track
of that stuff um but otherwise in terms
of like
friends and peers
last summer when i started writing about
race and
criminal justice and writing these
things that were so
contrary to the mainstream narrative i
did lose
a lot of friends a lot of especially
followers on instagram like people
in my city that i went to school with
because
what i'd what i had written was so
apparently
offensive to them and you know it was
mostly you know white people who you
know took offense to
my critiques of black lives matter and
critiques of
intersectionality and the whole white
privilege narrative
um so so there's definitely not a social
incentive
to write the things that i do um
in terms of like younger people um and i
do have my close friends which is great
um but but there is um
a benefit to doing that when you're
talking about the larger culture when
you're talking about
um just older people
you know when i started writing last
summer
um a lot of people came and supported me
and were sharing my stuff on twitter and
you know people like christina summers
and and um
recently i on her cle um her and i are
going to be collaborating on some stuff
so
so you know for younger people you know
i've lost lots of friends but i've made
lots of new ones too so
so there's a downside to it and i guess
you know a positive
as well yeah that's generally what
happens when you start
telling the truth or getting into more
serious topics is you're going to come
across people that
aren't okay with that but you do come
across people that support you for that
so that's good
why did you why did you even get started
writing about this stuff i mean given
when did you start writing first and
then why
these topics yeah so
i started blogging in high school
about uh usually rap music
and uh world cup soccer and
just like kind of satire comedy writing
about my life like just like funny stuff
that i like went through in high school
like just anecdotes
like just for fun um and i used to get
teased and
and mocked and ridiculed quite a bit for
it
because um it was just odd for somebody
to have a blog
and i just did and no one really read it
so it was just for me
i guess um and then
when i graduated from high school in
this would be 2018 summer of 2018
um i i wasn't really sure what to do
with myself and
before that i wanted to go to harvard
or stanford or columbia you know one of
these big schools
and my grades just weren't good enough
you know i was never the
the academic superstar by any stretch so
i had to take this year off and and i
had no idea what was ahead
and i was depressed for a while because
i had no idea what to do and i just felt
bored and lost and i feel like i didn't
have any meaning
um and then so this would be
um we're talking oh
yeah i graduated from high school in
2019 not 2018.
um and so now we're in 2020 and um
i published a few articles on rap music
and and hip hop culture in the globe and
mail
which was nice how did you so just just
pause there
how did you get some of these articles
into something like the glow and mail
uh just emailing around just saying hey
you know i'm young
i have some cool ideas and i want to
write about this
and it takes a lot of emailing like i
would say like for every
100 emails you'd hear like you hear back
on on 10 of them
maybe um and so
so i'd written a couple of articles on
hip-hop music
and then george floyd happened um in may
last year and then the race war was
reignited in the us
and in canada and all over the world
and uh and
then i i started seeing all this crazy
stuff happening
with with black lives matter and white
fragility
and the resurgence of
identity politics and and these were
issues that i had studied closely in
high school like just
for fun like i'd always been interested
in criminal justice
and um and identity politics especially
like it was just an interest of mine
throughout high school
and um one of the first people i started
reading
on this topic was coleman hughes
actually in
when i was in 10th grade i started
reading his articles i don't know how i
came across it
and they was really inspiring at that
point and and i was just
amazed at the way he presented a
different side
of the story like not just you know
racism and oppression but there's this
other side with
culture and history and all these other
things
um and so uh
so when george floyd happened after that
all the crazy race stuff
was happening and people were talking
about race and so then i did some
emailing around
and um i emailed the new york post and
then i got my first article published um
which was on white privilege and that
kind of went viral and it was blowing up
and everybody was sharing it
and that's when around there you asked
me to come on your show and
i was just so overwhelmed with
everything that i didn't know
what was going on but then since then i
guess that was the start of it
um and then after that consistently
writing about race
and culture and policing for a number of
publications
okay interesting so coleman hughes
he kind of led you down this route well
that's good like you don't hear
i want to get into a few of the articles
you've written in case our in case the
people listening don't aren't familiar
with your work you have
i'll read off a couple and then i want
to talk about them
you have the fallacy of white privilege
and how it's corroding society
was that that first article yeah yeah
the one that went viral
yeah so you've got that guy you've got
teaching white fragility is bad for kids
of color
which is pretty straight up that's also
new york post
uh and then you have this one's a good
one too a peculiar kind of racist
patriarchy
and that's that was an interesting one
that i want to get into
and then another article or it was
written somewhere it's called no cause
for alarm
different demographic groups excelling
in different areas of endeavor
does not prove discrimination so it's
pretty
pretty black and white um what your
feelings are
and i think it's interesting because
well you're young
one you're brown so you don't get as
much
i'm sure you get direct hatred for the
articles you write but because you're
not white
it gives an interesting perspective i
think you also had an article about
racism you've experienced you've written
about that a little bit too
yeah that's the one um on white
privilege i talked about that briefly
in the beginning yep okay so
can we can we start with
um the a peculiar kind of racist
patriarchy you talk about asian and
muslim women so can you give us a bit of
a background about that article
yeah um so that article was by far my
longest one
that was in uh december i wrote this and
it was like six thousand words
so there's just so much in there um so
is there something you wanted to start
on
in particular should i just um you can
talk but
what i wanted to start on was i just
wanted to talk about
i guess the what we're told about the
patriarchy and whether or not that's
true what your feelings are
about it and what this science actually
says or the data suggests
right so so one of the things and i
guess maybe we can start with
with the racial aspect and then bring in
gender into it too just because it's so
complex so one thing that i cited in
that article
was the multitude of groups
in the u.s ethnic groups that were
out earning whites by substantial
margins
so these groups were indians vietnamese
americans syrians turkish people
japanese korean nigerian groups all
these groups
and by the way just to back up a lot of
people ask me why i talk about
american issues more than canadian
issues like um
you know why don't i just talk about
what's happening in the us with regards
to these disparities
and the answer to that question is
is that um canadians
care about american issues but not the
other way around and so if i want the
the widest possible reach i just
i talk about the american stuff and then
people in canada they read it and
it's irrelevant here but if i just talk
about disparities here in canada then
it has kind of a limited scope
yeah and also like whatever whatever
cultural phenomenon
is happening in the u.s just tends to
permeate borders and
go to the uk and australia and canada so
you know whatever's going on
blm climate change or whatever then it
just
it just comes into canada automatically
so so it's almost like
i'm kind of like ahead of the game when
i'm like you know tackling american
issues because
they become relevant here in my city in
my town
you know in toronto everywhere right um
so so back to the article um all these
multitude of groups are out earning um
white people and and you can look at
other metrics too like education
test scores crime rates um
you know asian people uh asian americans
are much less likely to be killed by the
police
than white americans are right that's
not because the police
support asian people or they
discriminate against white people but
it's because
asian americans have extraordinarily low
rates of crime
and so that's the explanation for for
why that happens
um but but ultimately like this data it
just
it it refutes the idea that that race is
the key determinant to success
that your race being white
determines you being successful in
society right
in reality it's different cultural
patterns it's behavior
its attitudes towards education
um that essay in particular focused a
lot on
on cultural differences and i looked at
the cultural patterns among asians
and and one of the things um that i
found was that
asians are most likely to believe in
self-made success they're most likely to
display attributes of personal
responsibility compared to all other
groups interesting
tend to spend more time on homework less
time watching the tv
um you know you can control for
socioeconomic status and these
disparities still
exist right so low-income asians
tend to have higher upward mobility than
low-income
blacks whites and hispanics um
so it's so it's not just that you know
rich asian immigrants come
and and they just you know come they
just rise up to the top of society
it's they bring their their cultural
patterns and their attitudes towards
life
um and that's in large part
what accounts for their success
that's that's very interesting if we
were it's too bad that there's so much
nonsense about you know oppression
um caught like making people not succeed
and just giving people that excuse kind
of right while i'm in this group of
people which means i'm going to have a
harder time which means the reason i'm
not succeeding is because of oppression
which means there's nothing i can do
about it and it basically in my opinion
it wedges people into this hole that's
really hard to climb
out of if you're trapped in it by your
own beliefs
so it's quite poisonous that way i
wonder if there's a way that we could
take some of this information that we
have like the attitudes towards
education that come from
immigrant asian families and try and
potentially instill that in other people
because
there's definitely nothing wrong with
personal responsibility or
focusing on like it sounds like perhaps
they just work harder and i've also read
so you can tell me whether or not this
is true
i've read that after a few generations
of being in the us
this kind of goes away and they end up
pretty americanized and they don't end
up with this upward trajectory like they
would if they were
first generation immigrants or second
generation immigrants
have you done any research on that yeah
i think yeah i remember briefly
um reading about that i'm not sure what
the cause would
be but but this is like
poison from all their peers around yeah
right well
well you know it's you know it's all
about balance right like you know some
um asian students like they're just so
focused
on academics that they're not sleeping
well they're not
uh maintaining their health and all they
want is to get those a's get into
harvard
and and other people like they want more
balance like they want to
invest more time in sports and art and
you know i was you know i guess i'm
technically asian i'm south asian
but you know i was never the academic
superstar you know i always try to
balance between
um being creative because because that's
just the way i am i'm just
a very ambitious and outside of the box
type of
of thinker um so maybe it's
it's asians um as they go down the line
third fourth generation maybe they have
more of a balance with work
life and and other things and that could
cause for
i guess lower economic outcomes but
maybe
higher you know otherwise lifestyle
outcomes that could be the case
it's possible it's possible although
i've also read that the more money you
are in the happier you are
somebody right i think it wasn't did you
yeah
it was in the club there was an article
and it was like i think so i don't know
if it was the quill at
but it was happiness is directly
correlated to income
right but the line just doesn't go to
infinity right it just doesn't keep on
going there's a certain point
oh you know what i'll link it below i'll
send it to you after this okay
the study that i was sent anyway it was
basically i don't know how it would just
continue because i don't know how happy
you can get
but the study i read and it was done on
hundreds of thousands of people
and it was just like the more money you
make just the happier you are
okay for who for who knows how long i
was like oh
okay right yeah one one study i have
looked at maybe this is a different one
was that it it go it increases the
happiness as you get more money but at a
certain point you you hit
you know a flat line like like if you
have 30 million or if you have 100
million
oh how much materially more happy could
you be right but you know
yeah what i was taught i think my dad
probably told me this when i was little
was that as soon as you have enough
money to pay your bills
so it was something like 70k then your
happiness kind of plateaus no matter how
much money you had
contrary to popular belief but then i
read this new study and it was like no
that's not true just the more money you
have the happier you are
oh yeah well yeah maybe your dad's wrong
you know
it does happen occasionally but we don't
publicize it we don't publicize it okay
okay we can cut this part out
uh okay i like that i like that article
did you get a lot of kickback for that
so how what do people say when you get a
negative response to an article like
that when you're literally
citing like it was it was almost a
scientific article
yeah like you were citing studies it was
rock solid so what kind of negative
feedback do you get from something like
that um
just that i don't understand how racism
manifests in our society that i don't
understand how the patriarchy
is manifesting itself you know the the
oppression that women face
and that was the other part of the
article was the patriarchy oh yeah so
there was a race part but then i kind of
merge it with
with um ethnic um female groups
that were out earning um white women and
also white men
um so one finding was that in
2020 asian women had marginally higher
weekly earnings than white men which was
an unprecedented outcome it's never
happened before
right because there are so many
differences between the sexes right in
terms of hours spent
you know working and raising kids and
all these other things it's never like
an equal
comparison unless you yeah unless you
account for the variables and you have
an apples-to-apples comparison which you
can do
um but just the fact that asian women
had slightly higher incomes than white
men was just it was shattering
um to this narrative that that race and
gender
determines your success and and
i was confused at first and
and also fascinated why asian women
would
have higher earnings than white men like
i was just you know like why would this
be the case
and so i did some digging i talked to
some experts and i looked into the
studies and
there are a lot of cultural patterns
that
asian women display that that make it
obvious
why they would have such extraordinary
outcomes economically and education wise
so among all women asian women are most
likely to
major in high earning fields such as
stem
um and uh asian women
in general they tend to have fewer kids
and they tend to have fewer kids out of
wedlock
they tend to have fewer kids out of
wedlock um so they ten
they're more likely to be married when
they have their kids
uh and they tend to have kids a bit
later um
like a few years later than on average
than than whites and
and black women um and they tend to have
more
family support in raising their kids
which makes sense asian
families tend to be more like family
family oriented and
you know oftentimes grandparents and
parents can live together
and raise kids together and so all of
that
that's interesting i've never thought
about that i've thought about the fact
that they go into stem
but i haven't thought about the fact
that they might have a family set up
that makes
raising children easier i know most like
most white people i know who have kids
they live in different cities than the
rest of their family
like they're completely isolated um at
least from the people i know so that's
that's very interesting that's actually
a good find
yeah so all those cultural patterns
right it's it's not about
moral judgment right that was one of the
critiques that i got was that i'm you
know judging groups
um but you know you you know like asian
women they tend to have fewer kids than
white women and black women like that
there's no reason to judge that like if
if a woman wants to have
five kids that's up to her like some
women want more kids
but but asian women they clearly have
more of a career oriented bent
so they spend more time they devote more
time to their careers
and they have fewer kids the more
support so that leads to more financial
security
family stability more time devoted to
these things
um so all these cultural
patterns matter but
but the left just seems to completely
avoid these
explanations for for success in our
society because
the implication would be that its
culture its family its values that
determine success
not your white privilege not your male
privilege
not being straight you know all these
things um
you know it's not the patriarch it's not
systemic racism it's
individual groups and ultimately just
individuals right it doesn't matter
you know if you're asian or if you're
black you can you can
adopt different ways of thinking and
living your life
and uh pursuing what you want and
it doesn't matter what your race is you
can be successful and
i think i showed that in my article with
all these
ethnic women that were doing so well
one other thing that i showed was that
iranian women turkish women and
palestinian women
had higher earnings than white women in
the u.s and specifically
iranian and turkish women had higher
earnings than white men
and the reason why i looked at those
groups and why they stuck out to me was
that
it failed the whole intersectionality
test right because
a lot of iranian and turkish women they
would be ethnic
uh female and also a lot of them would
be muslim as well so
according to intersectionality they
would be you know triply oppressed or
you know however they do the their
pseudo mathematics of you know
calculating you know how
oppressed you are right um but compared
to white men they would be the most
privileged right but but muslim women of
immigrant background they would be just
so
oppressed but their earnings were higher
than white men
so that destroys that whole paradigm of
you know being of a religious minority
um being of ethnic background
dictates your success and and it's not
that i'm saying that
lots of muslim women don't experience
discrimination or ethnic people don't
right so in the article i cited surveys
showing that
muslim women do report experiencing some
level of
discrimination and and there are some
issues with those surveys like
and i can relate to this in my own life
as well like
if a white person like says something to
me in a rude kind of way like was it
because i'm brown or was it just because
right there is you know rude right like
that can be an issue and
it's hard to tell right because you know
race isn't everything right there are
lots of other reasons why people are
rude and stupid and
mean right um but but it's true that
discrimination exists and
i'm sure lots of muslim women have
experienced
discrimination especially after 9 11 and
this whole awakening about islamic
terrorism which is very real
but but you know human beings were were
wired to stereotype and generalize
and that can create racial stereotypes
in certain cases
right but clearly whatever
discrimination
and racism that exists in our society
it doesn't amount to a structural
barrier to success
which is the left's language that's what
they say
that that race that gender that these
determine success that they are
this um impenetrable barrier to
succeeding in society and
and my essay hopefully i showed um
persuasively that that just
isn't true yeah well it was a persuasive
essay but then you have to
you have to decide to read it and i
think if you're stuck in one
sort of like ideological framework then
it's less likely that you're going to be
able to get
budged whether or not the argument is
sound unfortunately
but that's very interesting
okay let's switch let's switch topics
let's go to one of your other articles
um anybody listening i do recommend
checking them out because they're very
well written and they're
they're pretty good if you have
left-leaning friends who argue about
some of these topics they're good to
read so you can get some of the data on
the subjects
um the so the next one um and i wanted
to get the background on this was
teaching white fragility is bad for kids
of color
so how did you this white i've had a
couple of people on now
um to talk about this white fragility
thing because
and rate like mandated anti-racist
courses at work and things because from
what i've read
they make people racist so that's just
horrible and the fact that a whole bunch
of people on the
like far left are really pushing these
anti-racism agendas
increasing racism is completely
unacceptable
uh so i've i've had a couple of people
on to talk about it um
chloe valderri yep coleman hughes was on
aisha conby she's really cool um
but you're so let's get into your
article a little bit um how did you
figure
that teaching white fragility is bad for
kids of color
yeah so there were two anecdotes in that
piece
which were really interesting the way
they happened and the time frame that
they happened in
so the first one was that my sister
um this was i think in december yes
december
my sister came home and she was really
upset because
a white boy in her class was making fun
of her for being brown
um and and that was and this is
vancouver are you in vancouver
so i'm actually in a small city called
chilliwack which is like an hour away
from vancouver
yeah you do oh how i i don't
i've been all over the random places in
western canada
so i know chilliwack uh my grandparents
on my mom's side live on
vancouver island i have cousins that
live in vancouver so
we've been all around all around there
but that makes a little
anyway continue to continue yeah yeah
yeah i always say vancouver because like
no one knows
what chillax is so you know i'm from
vancouver for
for all intents and purposes um so
uh so yeah so my sister came home and
she was really upset
about this guy who and you know the
comparison that he made was that you
know like your
skin colors you know it's like poo you
know like brown skin right
and that's your sister she is
eight turning nine soon ah yeah
okay i was thinking that sounds like a
little
like that sounds like a very young kid
yeah
yeah and yeah and it was just one time
and and that's an experience that i've
had multiple times throughout elementary
school
as well experiencing racism and so so
i've never once you know denied racism
which is
what i get accused of but it's like i've
written about it so
you know there's never any denial on my
part um
but my sister had experienced that and
she was really upset
um but but the school took it very
seriously including the teacher and the
principal
um they you know they phoned the kid's
mom um
and so he ended up making a card for her
saying that he was sorry
and my sister forgot about it within
like a week so it wasn't like a huge
like deal to start protesting over but
but it was you know an example of racism
and
just showing that it does exist right um
and then within like the same week my
brother came home
and he was talking about being in
english class and his teacher was like
pretty
you know pretty left-leaning and from my
interactions with that teacher like she
seems really nice and
um she seems like a good teacher but she
was
teaching all of this pro blm
and pro like identity politics stuff in
the class
you know talking about how black people
are you know are scared for their lives
from
the police and how there's an epidemic
of
racist police killings and showing
videos on that
um 15
so high school high school english class
yeah
and what kind of videos are these um
like just obviously
like ted talks like these anti-racist
speakers like ebermex candy giving talks
about
systemic racism that type of thing right
and this this all comes down from like
from what i understand like
the education uh ministries like they
they like mandate now to like teach more
like pro diversity
more um you know i guess woke kind of
curriculum like
teach people more about racism and i you
know i don't have a problem with
teaching
you know more history about racism
um and that kind of thing but the
direction it's taken is like a
completely
radical one-sided direction that's you
know anti-police and
people of color are oppressed that type
of thing
and uh in one class the teacher was
talking about
white fragility um how white people at
large they just
they uh display this kind of fragility
when
um faced with issues of racial
inequality
and how that makes them um oblivious
or ignorant to issues of racism
so what does that mean exactly like when
they're when they're saying something
like white fragility
what what are what does that mean well
what i just said that's the premise
that that when faced with issues of
racism white people they get defensive
they don't understand
okay because they're in here yeah before
they say that doesn't exist
yeah or yeah it doesn't exist put into
the white fragility
yeah area the problem is is like
universalizing
like one trait with a certain race
like you know one historical example is
the idea
of of uh of black lawlessness black
criminality like you know throughout us
history there was a stereotype of black
people being
dangerous inherently for genetic reasons
right
and so crime with stereotype is a black
thing right and now you know we
recognize like okay that is wrong
that's not true we shouldn't stereotype
all black people
you know in that way right racial
stereotypes are wrong
and that's what people like mlk
throughout history advocated for
but now there seems to be this this
embracing this
perpetuation and promotion of racial
stereotypes about white
people which are just completely
acceptable no one says anything
right you know whiteness is a problem in
our society and we have to dismantle
uh whiteness in all its manifestations
and and so my brother was just really
uncomfortable in that class and kind of
confused
um and the teacher didn't really explain
what white fragility is exactly
and thankfully that from what i
understand that was just
one class so it wasn't a huge deal um
but i know this happens across the u.s
in different schools
um there's a guy named christopher ruffo
you've probably seen his tweets
he reports on the difference he's always
viral on twitter he was like yesterday
like reporting on all the schools that
teach this anti-racist
radical ideology uh there was one that
he showed yesterday about the school
in new york showing the
different types of um white
characteristics like there's like white
supremacists and there's like
privileged white people then there's
like white abolitionists at the bottom
like people who want to
abolish their whiteness and stand up for
anti-racism
and they're like teaching this to young
impressionable minds
in in elementary school middle school
high school
and so you're and so you're breeding
this generation of increasingly
radical woke you know quote-unquote
anti-racist
group of of young people and the
outcomes are going to be really horrible
and we're seeing this already
you know over the past decade with
college campuses and it's going to
continue to get worse if we don't stop
teaching this insanity to young people
who
who when faced with this stuff they
don't have an alternative viewpoint to
look to they turn on
you know if they turn on cnn or if they
look at instagram live they look at
aoc and sean king and and there's blm
protests everywhere
and the narrative is all about
oppression
right they see that and then that
becomes their
their life goal that becomes their
spiritual mission and that's
that's that's problematic because
because young people do want to find
meaning right
in their lives and this is a whole
different topic we can
talk about which is you know young
people and and their struggles to find
meaning
in this age yeah that's really
that's really scary and i think a lot of
people who either
don't have kids or who aren't paying
attention don't realize that this is
what's going on in school's curriculum
like i know in 2016 when i kind of did
when dad was talking about it and i kind
of did background research it wasn't
a big deal in canada but i don't know
how that's
changed in the last five years
but it doesn't sound like it's changed
for the better is this do you think that
this is just the norm in public schools
um yes i'm like i'm increasingly coming
across
case after case where this is happening
across the u.s
um you know i was reading this one thing
recently about schools that
like are handing out these worksheets to
young people about like
categorizing their different identity
traits according to oppression
versus privilege so you know like brown
kids are like saying
okay i'm brown you know i'm female or
you know i'm gay or you know whatever so
i'm oppressed and if you're white you're
privileged and all this stuff
like i'm hearing more and more of this
and just the fact that i'm hearing so
many
cases i think indicates that there are
so many more that we're not hearing
about
right because just you know who's going
to report on this stuff there's one guy
that i know
the guy you know chris ruffo who he was
on dave rubin recently
and megan kelly's show and he's getting
a lot of attention which is great
but this is slowly growing and it's it's
this
reconciliation with racism after
george floyd um so it's starting from
the right idea right ending racism but
it's just taken this totally
radical perverse direction where
it's all white people are privileged or
racist and
people of color are oppressed and that
frequently happens with social movements
right they start off
in a kind of noble way and then they
just degrade
and become this totally radical thing
that is very hard to
support yeah almost when they get too
big
right yeah and they and the kind the
radical currents of that movement start
to
be promoted and it becomes mainstream so
you know it goes from
yes there are problems with policing yes
there's police brutality
let's try to fix the police and you know
better fund them let's
let's support them and ensure that
they're accountable right it starts from
that place and then it goes to
defund the police reduce the police or
potentially even
abolish the police which is the position
of uh blm founders and
and so people they're faced with this
choice of
supporting the movement or not and
especially white people
they're they're afraid of being called
racist so
so they just go along with it there's
pro blm and
and you know the radical parts of blm
they just overlook it
you know they just have to support it
because they're under this the social
pressure to
conform with the the social justice
trends of the day
yeah i know a lot of people too who are
pro blm
and their pro blm i don't think because
i don't know
if they're neces they're probably afraid
of beco uh being called racist
but they actually truly believe that the
movement is good for people
which is so a lot of people are just
confused and they don't see these
underlying
motives um but this stuff that's being
taught in school is a real disaster i
have a
i have a toddler and i was like i'm not
putting her in like i don't know what to
do exactly she's three and a half yeah
i was like i'm not letting her get
taught
that stuff because like what a waste of
time too it's not
not only is it bad for you but what are
you even gonna do with the information
you can't make money off of it like it's
just not useful information if you're
gonna go to school you might as well
learn things that you can
get a job from or maybe well you can you
can make money
you can make money out of it if you're
robin d'angelo and you're selling your
diversity seminars and
i don't know how many tens of thousands
of dollars per seminar
that she gets right so it is lucrative
for a lot of people by the way
but but you know in all seriousness even
scarier
so they made it into a business yeah
yeah they're they're
they're they're living off of this the
snake oil
right basically this diversity training
racial bias
training which study after study shows
that
it's not effective it tends to reinforce
racial stereotypes
so it does like the exact opposite of
what it's supposed to do
in many cases but it's it's a way for
you know schools and corporate america
top
companies tech firms law firms it's a
way for
them to shield themselves of accusations
of
of racism because of you know if if a
law firm has you know seven percent
black lawyers and and black americans
are
twelve percent of the population and and
they're doing all their can to hire
the best you know black lawyers but they
just have seven percent
you know people can come after them
activist groups and say that this is
bias this is
systemic racism so so it's kind of like
they
hire robin d'angelo to come in and and
teach lectures on diversity training as
a way to
protect themselves of these horrible
accusations
that totally makes sense so they don't
even care but they don't want these
groups to come after them
so they're saying while we're
implementing the courses we're trying
go focus on somebody who's not doing it
yeah yeah totally
for sure uh that's screwed up yeah
yeah so what do you like have you
thought about alternatives what
people should do because what are people
supposed to do with their kids
they just unbrainwash them when they
come home
like or not send them to school and then
send them where like i guess people
should just start talking out about
like about it more like what what are
your suggestions for how to change this
around because it seems to be getting
worse
and worse and worse yeah
yeah it does um you know you could do it
uh
what megan kelly did she just like
pulled out her kids from school because
it was just too
radical it was too ideological
re-education camp type thing um
and a lot of people are pulling their
kids out of school i've heard about this
um that's not really a solution right
you have to send your kids to school
at some point i'm not sure i have the
answer to your question i guess it just
doesn't have an answer i guess it just
comes from you know send your kids to
school
make sure they're learning about the
right things
and have dialogues with teachers
principles make sure that it's not
ideological that yes you can learn about
anti-racism anti-bullying that kind of
thing but if it starts going towards
the radical direction then it's time to
call up the teacher and say look this is
wrong
this is where this is getting out of
hand and
so i guess engaging in these kind of
dialogues and making sure that
your kids are being taught the right
things
i remember when i was so when i was in
grade four we didn't have
i don't think i learned any type of
anti-racism thing
in grade four i don't think that was
taught but there was a lot of focus on
anti-bullying uh and even the way that
was taught
i remember in grade 4 thinking it was
stupid it was like
it was kind of we were taught to feel
sorry for bullies because they were
probably coming from a hard place
and i was taught at home like just you
know kick them and they'll stop bugging
you like it was just the complete
opposite of what i was taught at home
but uh there definitely wasn't i'm 29
when i was in grade four i don't even
think in a high school
there was a lot of anti-racism
stuff like i'm and i graduated in 2010 i
think or 2009
and it really wasn't there so it but
then when i got to university it started
so that was 2011 or 2012 when i saw it
happening so
how long has it been going on for you in
school
yeah so even i can't remember anything
concrete in terms of
anti-racism in elementary or middle
school or high school actually like i
remember anti-bullying
going on but this is a very recent
phenomenon
like recent as in past few years and now
past few months
so just broader like just broadly
speaking
in terms of the culture what's happened
is it's kind of like
racial awakening this like turn towards
whatever you want to call a woke
ideology um
critical race theory intersectionality
all these kind of things and it's
happened
i would say since like around 2012 2013
and especially with the rise of rise of
trump um
there's a a political scientist his name
is zach
goldberg who's done some interesting
research on this
and he's found that over the past
um i think it was over the past
five years um
news outlets and publications have
significantly
increased the amount of stories that
they have on racism
and prejudice and outlets like the new
york times and the washington post
they've increased usages of the term
systemic racism
white privilege by up to like 500
percent or even 1 000
like the amount of times that they use
it in their articles over the past five
years and it's it's not that they're
increasing the amount of coverage of
racism
and it's you know racism is increasing
right by all measures racism has been
decreasing since
since the 90s and the 80s significantly
you know you can look at
polls you can look at surveys of
people's attitudes towards
you know interracial marriage and the
attitudes have increased you know
we live in a post i don't know if i want
to stay close to racial but we live in
an increasingly diverse society where
racism
is kind of you know at the margins it's
becoming increasingly
rare but for whatever reason
in the popular culture racism has been
kind of fetishized and
it's it's dominated our discourse
especially after i guess blm would be
maybe
one root cause of it so after michael
brown trayvon martin
you know a few black americans that were
killed by the police
it just led to this wave of anti-racism
and then publications and news outlets
they adapted to these
racial grievance narratives and then it
permeates throughout pop culture and
you know sports and you get lebron james
saying that you know black people
whenever they
they leave their front door they're
afraid of being hunted down by
you know police officers or one recent
example
you know that i give was uh naomi osaka
the
highest paid female athlete in the world
the famous tennis player
and after the jacob lake shooting last
year she was saying that
there's this continued genocide of black
people at the hands of police officers
and uh and then this goes to you know
the president
of the united states now joe biden you
know talking about
you know when black people wake up
they they're afraid of their lives right
this was uh
one of his promotions one of his
promotional campaigns
uh before the election him and kamala
harris kamal o'hara said that
black people have never been treated as
humans
in our society right after the jacob
lake shooting happened
which is something that i wrote about
recently as well yeah
how is yeah i'm so skeptical of
my dad's always like yeah the america
will turn around like
things looked pretty pretty pretty bad
in the 60s and 70s and with the vietnam
war
like people were protesting things were
crazy and and america recovered
i don't i'm a little bit more skeptical
because i
it looks like it's not going in a good
direction and i've been looking at like
where do where do i move to if things
get really bad where this doesn't exist
but it seems to be
permeating basically the western world
yeah yeah especially the major cities
like you know i guess toronto vancouver
and new york city la that type of thing
a lot of people are leaving you know
more progressive cities moving
um in other places like austin texas
there's this whole
exodus of people you know started with
you know joe rogan last summer leaving
to austin and
a bunch of comedians now and i think tim
dillinger mosque
he's going there elon musk yeah i think
so yeah yeah and
tim dillon was talking about this
recently the comedian of going to austin
texas
and a bunch of people moving there for a
variety of reasons including
you know lockdowns and you know at first
the riots wildfires and all these other
things
wild year yeah yeah yeah definitely a
wild year for sure
i kind of thought with covid that would
it would quell that a little bit
but then things went totally to [ __ ]
in the summer but i thought you know oh
we're in a pandemic like everyone's kind
of
equally affected although they've turned
that into a racial thing too
but i thought that that would bring
people it did i think for the first
couple of months they're
like so the social justice warrior kind
of movement
was silent and then it just erupted
yeah yeah it just it just erupted after
after george floyd happened and
it was just like absurd to me i feel
like i was like high on like
psychedelics like looking into what was
happening like
all these like protests were happening
and you know if kobe exists like
and you know if all the alarmism is true
then those protests
were a horrible idea all those riots you
know all the property destruction
but like you had like top [ __ ] like
health officials saying
racism is a bigger problem than kovid go
protest
but restaurants you know in la no we're
locking down i don't know that's bad but
protest yes
racism is a disease let's go fight it
like real health experts
medical doctors are saying this is super
weird
what the [ __ ] are you saying like either
either your alarmism is true right
either you know stand by what you're
saying
you know or they just go down this woke
direction and it's like
it's like there's like this like
parasite in their mind like they just
become blind to
what they believe in favor of woke
ideology
it's it's insane yeah well people are
scared it's easier just to i mean if
it's like
15 minutes of you in front of a camera
being like yeah i guess protesting is
fine like wear masks but this is a
really serious cause keep at it
you're doing the right thing and then
they can go home and have dinner and
they're like hoof well
dodge that bullet right even if that's
not what they should be saying
uh yeah what a disaster well i hope
everything doesn't go to [ __ ] but at
least if it does it'll happen in the u.s
first and then it'll trickle up to
canada and
we can go move somewhere else before it
hits us really hard right yeah
yeah so yeah maybe we have canadian
privilege or something like we're
sort of protected a little bit but but
you know the stuff that
it just permeates you know across the
borders and we get protests here and
you get you get um black lives matter
just
existing in all parts of like canadian
society everybody's talking about black
lives matter and
uh you know you have local newspapers
talking about this
ad nauseam um and that kind of thing
one thing that happened last summer when
i started writing about this
was you know i guess the outrage among
young people
especially and eventually as i was
writing more and more about these things
it was clear that me writing about these
things
as a as a brown skinned man
as an ethnic minority was
deeply disconcerting
troublesome and perplexing to some
people
like a lot of older even progressive
people that were looking at me like what
is this guy doing like he's not you know
following the following the line of you
know vocism and you know
systemic racism all these ideas and
and the local newspaper editor here in
my city he
repeatedly called my articles alt-right
like he called me alt-right like the guy
who runs the newspaper in my city
called me alt-right like several times
recently as in like
last month in january he did like saying
after i
wrote uh an article on the jacob blake
shooting and all that happened and how
the media
misinterpreted that case and it turned
out to be a justified shooting
you know despite all the riots and all
the chaos you know i wrote about that
and then he was like oh this is an
alt-right
article this guy's brainwashed by
alt-right ideology and
and uh and this started off from like
when i wrote about joe rogan in the
globe and mail
and just just so bizarre like well we
could talk about that after but
yeah i've been called alt-right which is
amazing and i was looking back on my
article on white privilege um yesterday
after like months of
you know not looking at it and one of
the things that i said in there was that
being a person of minority background
is very advantageous in these
circumstances when writing about these
things
because nobody can call me alt-right
right and
and that is still a privilege that i
have as in
you know a white guy just doesn't have
as much credibility on these issues as i
do because
i can say i've experienced racism and
that's unfortunate right
that i can use my identity to win more
points which i do
right so when i say when somebody says
you know after reading one of my
articles no you don't understand
racism you know especially if a white
person says that i can say i have
experienced it which is real
so i'm not denying it i'm not you know
some anti you know
you know somebody who's who's um
oblivious or ignorant to these things
but but it's remarkable how even i was
grouped into that alt-right
category but i think that just shows
more about the person saying it than
anything about me like it just
you know in some ways it even kind of
helps me like when people see that
they're like
this is insane like then people start to
support you and it just shows like how
absurd and and ridiculous this person is
that's saying these
things you know online and and elsewhere
yeah hopefully it's pretty weird world
it does it doesn't seem to matter what
your background is
in order to be deemed all right yeah but
definitely
definitely being minority helps though
definitely helps it does
so yeah and that's by the way like like
talking about white privilege like
you know i have a privilege in that way
that i have brown skin whereas you you
know you michaela you're white right if
you write the things that i do you know
that's your white privilege talking
right nobody can say that about about my
stuff right so that's a privilege
yeah well i use that sometimes when i'm
talking about health aspects
as you get like because they're used to
there was a big movement i went to
concordia and montreal and there was a
big movie
about disabilities and supporting people
with disabilities and i was like
to a degree that's important depending
on the disability
but the way they were going about it was
absolutely ridiculous and
i had more of a right i didn't get as
much hell for talking about it because i
was like no
i fall into that group at the moment i'm
not anymore but i
fell into it before and i was like what
are you gonna say man you have arthritis
you bitching about it like
[Music]
um pretty weird okay okay let's
let's end off with your uh joe rogan
article yeah yeah that was just not
about it
yeah that was just a bizarre thing like
i i still can't believe that even like
happened
like i feel like maybe it was some kind
of satirical thing maybe
or maybe the twitter algorithm messed up
or something but
but i wrote an article praising joe
rogan in the globe and mail
in october of last year and it went
viral
on twitter trending number one in canada
because of widespread outrage
among progressive celebrities
journalists
activists on twitter like they're like i
was going through like thousands of
comments from blue check mark people
outraged over me you know supporting you
know a guy who platforms
alt-right people like jordan peterson
and ben shapiro
and you know all these kind of things
and and the guy who's misogynistic and
transphobic as well for having on you
know deborah so
abigail schreier all these things and
like it was like it was it was insane
like i'm going through these tweets and
it's like
you know this young kid this rav he's
he's been brainwashed by you know
watching
you know joe rogan and listening to
jordan peterson and all these things
and it was just it's like is that really
where we're at right now we're like
you know supporting you know a podcast
listened to by
hundreds of well i don't know millions
of people at least right the number one
podcast
in the world everybody you know you know
top scientists academics
journalists want to go on that show like
like either like if it's true that
you know his podcast is genuinely
supporting
racist and transphobic things then then
we're screwed right then tens of
millions of people are also racist and
transphobic but maybe
that's why this anti-racism movement is
growing
maybe joe rogan is making everybody
racist and they're just fighting against
it
right yeah yeah it could be the case but
but just like the progressive like
allergic like resistance to just like
things that they disagree with like just
the fact that a guy like joe rogan
just platforms people on the right on
the left you know on the center people
who have
heterodox views like just him doing that
is
is heretical it it violates the
the norms of the progressive orthodoxy
and
you know it's wrong and we must condemn
it and you know a young kid
you know that's the way that they framed
it was like this young kid who
you know just supporting this alt-right
you know platformer like it's just
deeply wrong and
and so just going away from that it's
you know i guess i did get you know
publicity for it so you know my follower
count increased so maybe that's a silver
lining i guess
but it was just like this perfect
illustration of just how far
the woke identity politics have gone
that we can't even
just agree on basic things and share
just basic respect for each other and
allow for
intellectual and ideological diversity
yep it's pretty scary hopefully it turns
around but
it may not we'll see i think i'm going
to i think i'm going to end up trying to
make
my own school in toronto for scarlett
your own school
well maybe get a bunch of other little
kids she's little right she's three and
a half she doesn't have to start
learning serious things for a little
bit she's just learning the basics but
maybe get a couple of kids together and
try and do it that way
um because oh okay i don't have it in me
to be like a homeschooling mother
but if i could i know some people who
would be good at it so maybe that's a
way to do it
because i don't see how you can put your
kids in yeah
school yeah yeah you're the uh you're
you're the uh the barbie doll
trump spokeswoman right that's that's
your future right that's what future
yeah
when trump runs again like you know in
2024 he's looking for candidates and
and that other blonde girl she's like i
can't take his [ __ ] anymore and he's
like who am i going to [ __ ] hire
michaela peterson she she seems like the
person who just freaking
kicked kick you know reporters of the
balls and just like freaking
[ __ ] off and just you know that's what
you would do right
ah probably not finally at least there
might be an opportunity there it's been
publicized
maybe yeah yeah yeah after that article
which was man that was insane what
how that happened right yeah that was
crazy insane
for a few days we're not doing we're not
doing that again
rav where where can people find you
online like twitter instagram what are
your handles
uh twitter rav r-a-v-a-r-o-r-a-1
um and instagram i like to keep it
private so mainly just twitter you can
check out my stuff and
usually in the new york post and colette
and
other places great thank you very much
for coming on that was fun
yeah yeah for sure awesome
[Music]
you